>> I'VE BEEN TRYING TO MAKE IT
AS AN ACTRESS FOR YEARS, BUT I
WAS SICK OF DOING COMMERCIALS OF
PLAYING ONE DIMENSIONAL WOMEN
WITH VACANT LIVES.
THEN ONE DAY, LIFE CAME
KNOCKING.
THIS TIME WITH A CHALLENGE.
>> EXCUSE ME.
HELLO.
I'M GRACE.
ARE YOU THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FILM?
>> WHAT?
>> I'M THE LEAD ACTRESS.
I PLAY THE WOMAN WHO GETS
CHEATED ON IN THE GAY PORN.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT MY
LINE IF YOU HAVE A MOMENT.
I OPEN THE DOOR, AND I SAY,
JARED, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
NOT WITH MY GOD SON.
LIKE THAT?
IS THAT MY GOD SON?
>> YEAH.
>> FASCINATING.
>> YOU'LL PUT ON WHATEVER YOU
WANT FROM THE WOMAN THING.
YOU'LL GET YOUR MEAL VOUCHER
AFTER WE WRAP.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
OH, LUBE.
THE DIRECTOR'S METHOD WAS
GUIDANCE REGARDING THE
CHARACTER.
ALL I HAD WERE CLUES, PIECES, A
PUZZLE OF THIS WOMAN'S LIFE.
TWO PAIRS OF LOOSE SWEAT PANTS,
A SINGLE UGG BOOT, A COUPLE OF
BATTERIES AND SOME HAPPY
2017 GLASSES.
WHO ARE YOU, DEER DRAZ?
THAT'S THE NAME I GAVE HER.
THE FIRST SCENE WAS ROUGH.
>> ACTION!
>> I WAS HAVING TROUBLE FINDING
HER.
I'M GOING TO THE MALL.
PERHAPS I'LL GET SOME FLOWERS TO
BRIGHTEN UP THE PLACE.
THE HOUSE COULD USE SOME COLOR,
NO?
IF YOU NEED ME, YOU CAN REACH ME
ON MY CELL PHONE.
>> CUT.
JUST SAY WHAT'S IN THE SCRIPT.
>> I WAS JUST TRYING TO ACT AS
DEIRDRE.
>> THERE'S NOTHING TO HER.
PEOPLE ARE JUST GOING TO SCROLL
PAST YOU SO THEY CAN GET OFF.
SHE HAS NO PAST, NO FUTURE.
SHE EXISTS ONLY TO BE CHEATED
ON.
SAY WHAT'S ON THE SCRIPT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ACTION!
>> JARED, I'M GETTING MY NAILS
AT THE MALL.
NOW TEACH MY GODSON PUSHUPS
RIGHT BEFORE OUR WEDDING, JARED.
>> CUT.
THAT'S GREAT.
NICE AND FLAT.
ON TO THE REAL STUFF.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO WATCH, YOU
CAN SIT ON A FOLDING CHAIR JUST
OUTSIDE.
I'LL CALL YOU WHEN IT'S TIME FOR
YOU TO CATCH THEM IN THE ACT.
>> WHEN THEY BETRAY ME.
I WAS RIDDLED.
JARED, HOW COULD YOU?
I DIDN'T KNOW IF I WOULD FIND
DEIRDRE IN TIME.
NOT WITH MY GOD SON.
JARED, JARED.
>> WIFE, WE'RE READY FOR YOU.
>> AND THEN JUST WHEN I THOUGHT
SHE'D NEVER COME TO ME.
>> ACTION.
>> SHE DID.
>> JARED, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
NOT WITH MY GOD SON.
>> I SAW THE RICH AND BEAUTIFUL
BACK STORY OF THIS WOMAN.
HER CHILDHOOD, HER FIRST JOB,
THE NIGHT SHE MET JARED.
>> THREE, TWO, ONE, HAPPY NEW
YEAR!
>> THE PROMISES SHE WAS TOLD.
>> I WILL LOVE YOU, A WOMAN,
FOREVER.
>> HER GOD SON'S 18th BIRTHDAY.
>> I KNOW HOW MUCH YOU LIKE
BATTERIES.
>> AND ALL ANOTHER TIMES SHE WAS
BLINDSIDED BY LIFE.
>> JARED, SOMEONE BROKE IN AND
STOLE MY LEFT UGG BOOT.
JARED, YOU HAVE A SECOND CELL
PHONE?
JARED, WHY IS MY GOD SON
SLEEPING OVER?
I FELT THE BRUISES AND SCARS
FROM THE PAST.
I SAW WHAT LED HER HERE.
YOU WOULD NEVER HURT ME.
AND I SAW HER IN THE PRESENT,
WALKING IN ON THE LOVE OF HER
LIFE WITH HER GOD SON.
AND THEN DEIRDRE TOOK OVER AND
SAID --
JARED, I FORGIVE YOU.
>> CUT.
WE'LL EDIT THAT OUT.
JUST GIVE HER THE MEAL VOUCHER.
>> DEIRDRE, HOW DO I GET YOU OUT
OF ME?
I CAN'T TAKE YOU WITH ME.
I'M SORRY.
THIS IS IT.
GOOD-BYE.
>> OH, HOW DID I GET LUBE ON ME?